let's discuss the latest now on the
pandemic in more detail
joining me now is dr chand nagpul he's
chair of the british medical association
also joining us professor melinda mills
professor of demographic science also
sits on the sage group for behavioural
insights and dr barat pancanya senior
clinical lecturer at exford university
thanks very much all of you for joining
us we've been asking
people on twitter and
on our websites to get in touch with us
with their questions lots of people have
questions uh dr nagpul about
the dates of various boosters and things
that they may have had in in the past um
but let's start with with dr barrett
pancania um one question has come in
from sean on twitter he says why are we
not testing for antibodies routinely
wouldn't this help us ascertain immunity
in in the population
yeah sean the short answer is that
measuring antibodies is a
imprecise science and if you think about
it sean we've also got to take a needle
a syringe to your arm take some blood
out send the blood to the laboratory get
it
analyzed so it is a long tortuous
process to look for antibodies it's
expensive and furthermore the test the
test for the antibodies is not precise
enough for us to say i see antibodies
therefore you are immune
right so it's not very efficient and
it's not very precise pretty clear clear
answer there
let's let's move along the line to
professor melinda mills a demographic
scientist and also behavioral expert um
another question is it good public
health policy to force people to be
vaccinated or face restrictions and
discrimination both socially and
medically so clearly come from a
political angle but
in in a more in more general terms
does it work public good public health
policy
if restrictions are implemented do
people tend to stick to them
yeah so the question is about whether
you know mandatory
vaccines would be brought in and that
has been discussed in some countries
such as austria and germany but that
hasn't been the discussion here so
because generally you know other things
like incentives can be more effective in
you know and people understanding why
they need to be vaccinated and how it
works because really we have this large
middle group and some people aren't
vaccinated because they still have some
safety concerns and they want to discuss
it more and that's why we should have
more dialogue i mean there's just a very
small group that is actually against it
for for for other reasons often
non-medical so um you know things can
work such as you know sending reminders
to people making it convenient um having
longer opening times and we're really
experiencing that now that you know when
the when the prime minister uh gave the
announcement on sunday you had this rush
of people actually wanting to have the
vaccines and as you were just discussing
there's people around the world that are
really you know desperately wanting to
have these uh vaccinations so i think in
general you know the public has really
adhered and has really listened um to to
these things and as we enter into the
winter period they're understanding you
know why they have to wear face
coverings why
vaccinations are important so um we can
we can anticipate the similar amount of
adherence i would think
um dr chan negpol um lauren has written
in she says is there any known
difference with catching the omicron
variant during pregnancy i'm double
jabbed not yet though in the window for
a booster should there be any further
guidance for those who are pregnant
well the uh omicron variant has only um
come come to light very recently
and i haven't come across any government
guidance that is specifically about
omicron what i would say
is that because we know that um uh
pregnant women are at higher risk of of
complications or severity of illness
what should be done is to take extra
precautions not to put yourself at risk
if you're not yet eligible for the
booster
what that means is that the measures
around physical distancing not mixing in
crowds and what we at the bma are
promoting uh is that um uh the public
and especially pregnant women and others
who are vulnerable should be wearing
ffb2 masks these are higher grade masks
that protect the wearer uh um as well as
uh preventing transmission to others so
so those in higher risks should be
wearing in our view higher grade masks
they're readily available from any high
street pharmacy readily available online
as well
okay good advice um we've just had some
breaking news at the shadow chancellor
rachel reeves has tested positive for
cover 19. um dr pankenya um of course
the day is the day that the regulations
change don't if you've come into contact
with somebody who has covered 19 you
don't have to now self-isolate you can
do daily lateral flow tests is that a
concern for you in terms of the spread
of of the the new variant and the old
variant do you think numbers will go up
because the regulations have changed
yes i do and
this makes my job as a infectious
disease expert difficult very difficult
because we know we all know that the
latter floor devices are not accurate uh
there are two issues here one the
accuracy per se and the second bit is
how well did you do the test and i'm
often in outbreak control meetings
saying unless and until you do a really
good sample taking then your test is
meaningless so with respect to lateral
flow tests of contacts on a daily basis
it is a flawed process the floor being
you can game it nobody's checking
nobody's scrutinizing whether number one
you really did the test number two did
you do it properly and number three we
know inherently that the lateral floor
devices have a inbuilt inaccuracy
however i suppose dr kenny you could say
that those who are self-isolating for 10
days could also gain the system couldn't
they we they are not being checked every
day throughout that 10-day period so we
are
going on trust aren't we and professor
melinda mills um
social distancing this is a question
from sue and she says previously under
covert alert level four social
distancing was in place is this the case
now and if so why are people not being
advised they should be social distancing
and
how are people still social distancing
whether or it isn't the regulations or
not i wonder just subconsciously i
certainly feel that when i'm out and
about i
step back when i talk to people i i
don't stand as close to people as i used
to have has there been a change in
society and how we interact with people
yeah so we looked at multiple
self-reported surveys but also cctv data
reports about that and what we saw over
time when particularly in july when when
you know the message was given out that
there could be a relaxation of some of
the restrictions and some of the
interventions and we definitely saw a
drop and across all things um you know
people were encouraged to go back to
work we saw drop in face coverings and
um also social distancing so i think
those kind of really quite important
that people now understand and there has
to be some more clarity in messaging
because people you know need to know
okay well what do i need to do what
setting is it in
um you know why why is that new and why
would i need to do this and as soon as
you you clarify this and i think chris
williams has said it on multiple
occasions as soon as people understand
you know why they need to do it in the
urgency of it they will do it but i
think sue's raised an important issue
that there has been sometimes a lack of
clarity we can think about face
coverings for example
um you know
when they were only in certain spaces
such as transport or in shops and people
started to wonder why not in this space
and not in another so i think clarity of
communication will be another important
thing particularly as we go into the
holiday period
so do you think more government
messaging would would be useful because
it does perhaps feel quite a while since
the hands-face space logo was fostered
upon us repeatedly we don't sort of hear
any of those messages anymore do we
well i think also the science has
evolved and it's not that people have
been incorrect but there's a clear
understanding now you know transmission
of your error aerosol transmission and
droplets so ventilation really has to
enter into that factor as well and also
that idea about social bubbles that we
all you know grew to understand you
should have repeated contact within the
same networks of people over the period
that you should make sure you open the
windows because it's a winter period now
and you know all of that messages i
think you know it can't be repeated
enough and as soon as people hear it and
they understand and they have some
control and know what they need to do
people will generally you know
understand that and adhere to it okay
um another question uh from a viewer
concerned about about their safety dr
nag paul uh this is from ann and she
says my daughter's partner has covered
had covered two weeks ago he's well now
and and has antibodies
she has an autoimmune disease rheumatoid
arthritis is it safe for her to spend
christmas day with him or could he still
transmit the new variant to me there's a
lot resting on this answer dr nagpur
well if he's recovered from covet two
weeks ago of course it could have been
the delta variant uh and he may still be
therefore susceptible to um um
getting infected with omicron now i
think that the the important point is
that those who suffer with all human
conditions uh or have any other
vulnerable medical condition that places
them in a vulnerable position should um
be taking extra precautions now
not wait until when you meet someone at
christmas but now i said that earlier
that
you should wear a medical grade mask an
ffp2 mask so when you go out to prevent
yourself becoming infected protecting
you as a wearer but also being very
careful about mixing i think by doing
taking those measures you reduce the
likelihood of of being infected and
possibly transmitting it on to loved
ones at christmas the other thing that
uh and i totally agree with barrow that
there are limitations on lateral flow
tests but if they can be done properly
and and it does mean watching a youtube
video as well as reading instructions
they can be done properly and they've
done sequentially that there is a
pick-up rate that if you are an
asymptomatic carrier it will show that
you may be infected and taking those
precautions before you meet your loved
ones at christmas is important the third
is how you meet people it's not just
about meeting you can meet people
in a crowded room at christmas in a
crowded living room or you can meet with
a good ventilation which makes a huge
difference uh to the risk of
transmitting the virus and also uh with
more spacing out
and and having just fewer people
in the room so there are those measures
that will also reduce the risk so just
to summarize for anne you're saying that
that her daughter's partner may not be
potentially passing on delta but they
could potentially have omicron you know
if if they've got over delta
is that that's correct
yeah yes because if you it because two
weeks ago omicron was not particularly
prevalent in the uk so if you would have
got clover two weeks ago there was a
high chance it was delta and if it was
delta that doesn't make you immune
necessarily to omicron you're still at
risk uh certainly i hope that um
both the partner
and um
and itself should um have a booster if
they're both eligible but also
recognizing that it will take some days
after the booster to be fully protected
okay and the other advice where where uh
ffp mask uh they should all test before
they get together um and do lateral flow
tests and open windows uh dr pankanya
you were shaking your head during that
i'm just checking you know whether or
not you disagree or whether you were
agreeing there because one of the other
questions was from joe who said
link to that can you contract delta and
omicron at the same time if they are
significantly different strains or one
after the other so let me
let me answer both so i was shaking my
head because i was saying look the
gentleman has recovered from his delta
or whatever infection it was
there is every possibility that the
partner
or both the partners can get reinfected
and therefore you take precautions but
if her specific question is can we meet
over christmas my answer is yes he has
recovered from his last infection and
therefore continue with your infection
control measures and do mean don't
cancel your meeting so in answer to the
second question
i would say yes of course you can have
dual infections you can have a omicron
infection as well as a delta
virus infection the processes are the
same the recovery is the same some
people unfortunately end up in hospitals
and the best way to prevent that is to
be fully boosted
okay so you can have them both one after
the other or both at the same time that
that's useful to know um professor
melinda mills that there is uh obviously
this big political debate happening in
parliament today about further
restrictions it seems that a lot of
people have very entrenched views about
it some would describe some people as
being anti-vaxx some vaccine hesitant as
as we move on through through how this
disease has been presented and how
people have reacted to it once somebody
has decided that they're not getting a
vaccine is it very easy to change their
mind or or is that once that mind is
made up
is that it
well we've seen various opinion polls
about you know how large is that group
and that group is actually quite small
um that that is absolutely against uh
getting vaccines remember there's other
groups such as those that have alleries
or medical reasons um so we're not
talking about that group that's exempt
but actually there's just a really large
middle group or some people that have
had their their first vaccinations um
but not the second dose
or or that haven't come forward for the
booster shot yet and that's for various
reasons and i think we we often forget
that it could be complacency so for
example it could be you know younger
people thinking well wait a minute i you
know i don't risk hospitalization or
death and i think we have to shift you
know the narrative and thinking more
about
you know it's not just about you about
whether you're vaccinated but we have to
reach a sufficient level of immunity
within the population and that's why
it's important for you know younger
younger individuals and why they're
having that discussion as well about age
five and up and that's why it's so
important for for the population to you
know as many as possible to become
vaccinated and specifically
since we've had this discussion about
second doses and booster doses it's very
important um to you know have this
dialogue we know that there's just
many different reasons why and they're
not always that people are against it's
just a large group in the middle that
just needs some more information they
need some more community dialogue they
might need a mobile van you know coming
in their neighborhood because they have
time they find it difficult to get time
off work so it's a lot more reasons um
than just uh people being against it
interesting yeah a lot of it's just
about the access to it uh dr nagpul a
lot of people worried about christmas
and and plans uh james has has got in
touch he says my 12 year old son had
covered late october we need to wait 12
weeks until he can be vaccinated that
takes us right into mid-january
should i wait the full 12 weeks or is it
safe for him to have it sooner it's hard
to keep up with the guidelines as they
change so frequently so so should a 12
year old who had covered in october be
getting jab now or should he wait
okay so um i will actually have to refer
to uh professor pankania as an expert in
in in terms of vaccinations and
immunology but what i would say is that
uh as we approach the end of december
although the government has said all
adults will receive a uh a clovid boost
or be offered there will be about 11.5
million patients like the example you've
given of people who will not be eligible
for a booster because they've either not
received a vaccine or they've only
received one or the second was given too
recently to make them eligible so we're
going to have to go into the new year
with other with continued infection
control measures the booster program
even if we were to deliver it by the end
of december will not be sufficient to
protect the nation and now in terms of
um
what what you should do over christmas i
think the the the message that i've
given before is you need to meet safely
and there are a you know host of issues
to try and protect yourself before you
meet others at christmas to make sure
you meet in small numbers you have a
ventilated uh area you you you have
physical distancing wherever you can all
of those things will make a difference
including i know it may not be socially
acceptable but you can actually also
wear masks um
you know with people you know uh to try
and reduce that risk uh but in terms of
whether the government should change its
rules around uh
uh shorting the duration uh of time
between the second dose and the booster
that's not a decision for me no well
doctor pancake do you come up on that
because it was interesting listening to
the um the the politicians questioning
the experts this morning their
explanation of why we wait so long for
the vaccine
because actually it does work up to that
point it is a waste of resources a waste
of money in in one sense getting the
booster early um but but also it you
know it it brings the problem six months
closer down the line doesn't it if you
have the booster early only six months
time you got the same problem
but balancing that against the need to
vaccinate people to prevent omicron
infection
yes so um if you recall we initially had
a six-month interval between having your
two primary courses followed by a
booster at the six-month uh interval and
that has been shortened now and in
answer to the question about uh the
gentleman's son should he have the
booster my answer would be yes he should
and my reasoning is as follows the
infection that his son had in october is
now well and over where in december so
that's two months gone by all his immune
systems etc will have settled down
calmed down and now if he were to have
his booster today it would be perfectly
fine and there would be no cross
interference and reduced immune response
as a result of getting the job
in december rather than in mid-january
okay um professor melinda mills i wonder
whether um you know when we talk about
people who are are hesitant people
who've decided not to have the vaccine
rather than perhaps the people that you
were talking about earlier who just
haven't got it for various reasons to do
with logistics and things um
in terms of skepticism towards the
medical profession a lot of people
suddenly seem to think they're they're
the experts because they've read a few
things online um
is that is that different now to how it
was you know i'm thinking back a hundred
years ago obviously we didn't have the
internet social media but have people
always been skeptical of medical
intervention
i mean are more people skeptical now or
or will there always be a percentage of
the population that are skeptical
we've seen a few changes over time so
definitely we see similar messages
almost completely um when smallpox when
that vaccination first was was
introduced we see similar sort of
discussions about it which is
interesting because that's uh you know
over 100 years ago but actually um
there's a few things is one is that we
have a different um sort of information
sources now so there's been multiple
studies that have shown that people that
get their their information from mult
from sort of alternative sources
particularly such as you you youtube or
tick talk
or some whatsapp groups they get
fundamentally different types of
information that hasn't been fact
checked and is often more negative and
often less given by
experts
and another thing that we found um also
we've published as a survey you know
looking at trust in government and we're
expanding that internationally and
really what you see is if people have a
low trust in government they see role
models not doing similar things um to
what they've been asked to do
um but also just um you know uh
looking at uh
inconsistency in messages that gets very
confusing for people but what we found
is that people and others have found
this as well people have high trust
still in experts and medical experts so
you know people such as the chief
medical officer or people from the uk
health and security agency they still
you know understand that you know
they're doing something for the for the
public good and sometimes they can be
more skeptical about uh the government
or politicians and that's around the
world but particularly the case in
polarized societies such as the uk the
us or brazil
how interesting uh well professor uh
melinda mills great to talk to you and a
great deal of confidence in the words
that we've had today from dr chan nagpul
and dr barrett pankanya fine experts all
of you thank you very much for joining
us and answering our viewers questions
appreciate it